[Music]
so before we get in to this deeper it's
important that we're all working from
the same definition of AI because there
are a lot out there so what is AI how
many of you think that machine learning
in AI are essentially the same thing
anybody how many people think AI
includes the machine learning and also
some rules based coding and also maybe
optimized search algorithms or sorting
algorithms yeah so AI really includes
usually some kind of combination of some
or all of those things and really
because machine learning is going to
give you some results but it doesn't
necessarily do anything with those
results I like to think of AI as a
system and not just an algorithm or an
ensemble of algorithms and I'll kind of
get into this a little more later
and my favorite definition of AI was by
Andrew Moore who was the former dean of
the school of computer science at
Carnegie Mellon University and he said
that artificial intelligence is the
science and engineering of making
computers behave in ways that until
recently we thought required human
intelligence so we're trying to get
computers to do things the way that
things that we used to think required a
human brain now there are two important
types of intelligence to distinguish for
our purposes today one there's a narrow
intelligence which is kind of the
current state of AI right now and it's
where models and systems can only handle
the information that they were built to
handle or the data that they were
trained on and they can't really
generalize the information that they
have to anything they've never seen
before or unlearned situations and then
the other kind of intelligence is
general intelligence and that's more
like human intelligence so we can
generalize information about cats and
dogs to other animals like maybe a goat
so right now if I trained an AI in
system on photos of cats and dogs kind
of like Alyssa was talking about earlier
and then that same system sees a picture
of a goat it can only tell you the
probability that that photo is a cat or
that photo is a dog it can't tell you
anything else and computers are kind of
dumb in this way so can we teach
computers to say oh I've never seen that
before
yeah we can do that with Thresh holding
so you could say all right I think 70%
this could be a dog maybe 50% this can
be a cat but we can build into our
system a role that says if you're not at
least 80 percent sure that it's either a
cat or a dog you could say I've never
seen this before so how does that differ
from how a human would would handle the
same problem well a human could do the
same thing if you are shown a picture of
an animal you've never seen before you
say I've never seen that animal before
but you know it's an animal and not a
tree or a human so we can still
generalize some of the information that
we have to things that we've never seen
before
hey I can't do this yet so should we be
afraid that AI will take over the world
short answer no like I said we are
lifetimes away I think from general AI
that can really kind of generalize and
learn a lot more and handle unseen
things and so right now computers can
only do what we train them to do they
can only get the information that we
give them either explicitly by dumping
data into them or implicitly by
equipping them with sensors to what to
collect their own data but the long
answer is there's still some ethical
concerns and things that can go really
wrong with AI
for example if we feed AI systems bias
data will get biased results and this
can have real-life consequences for
people so if you think about biases and
mortgage lending systems or credit
rating systems or employment
applications having biases in these
kinds of systems can be really
detrimental to people all right so why
has health care been so slow to adopt AI
well for the same reasons a lot of
industries have been slow to have been
you know hesitant just sometimes adopt
AI and we'll get into the kind of
universal reasons why
I can go wrong and white people are
hesitant to adopt it but there are a few
additional barriers in health care that
we have to overcome and one is heavy
regulation of the field especially with
the regulation of the way that personal
health information is handled makes it a
little more difficult I know in terms of
using cloud platforms a lot of places
have been very hesitant to send personal
health information through cloud
platforms for a variety of reasons a lot
of them are really legitimate reasons
and those things are being fixed right
like Google has options that can handle
HIPAA data for example and so we're kind
of headed in the right direction of
being able to use the lot more tools
like that in the healthcare field and
the other issue in healthcare that's
especially daunting and big barrier is
the gravity of potential damage so if
these systems make bad decisions you're
dealing with people's welfare their
lives people can die people can be
injured people can be seriously hurt and
so in addition to all the normal
barriers of AI there's some some pretty
big additional barriers in the field of
healthcare specifically so let's talk
about the the issue of bias data and how
this can kind of happen in one really
good example of a biased data problem is
Amazon's HR department and they are
reportedly used an AI enabled recruiting
software that would review and kind of
makes recommendations on which resumes
might be good candidates for different
positions well they found out that the
software was far more favorable to men
than to women because they trained it on
10 years prior to the adoption of the
tool and during those 10 years the
majority of candidates who are hired
were men and so the software or that the
program started to downgrade resumes
that contain words that implied that the
candidate was a woman so even though
they removed gender information from
what was being fed in if they saw
women's colleges for example it might
downgrade the resume now Amazon has
since abandoned this software and the
company said that they never used it
to actually evaluate candidates they
only use
for recommendations but this is still
problematic right because if you're if
you're getting a recommendation of
resumes to review even though you're not
using the software to actually evaluate
the client or the potential hire you're
still missing a lot of resumes of good
candidates who have been unfairly biased
and removed from the candidate pool okay
reinforcement learning so those of you
who are not familiar with reinforcement
learning reinforcement learning is a
special kind of AI where you kind of set
a computer loose to figure out the best
paths toward things so you do this using
like randomized search or exploration
into different possible actions and then
you set up this reward system so if it
makes a good choice that's rewarded and
it wants to maximize the reward right
and so these are really great systems if
you google reinforcement learning the
majority of results are usually around
teaching computers to play different
kinds of games and it's really fun you
know and so one of the most popular
examples is teaching a computer to play
Atari pong that's how a lot of people
get started learning how to do
reinforcement learning but reinforcement
learning is becoming prevalent in many
AI applications and it has some really
interesting real-world applications they
think could be very beneficial so one of
them would be explore exploration into
using autonomous cars for traffic
control flow so let's say a third of our
population gets into autonomous cars we
can program those cars to actually
control the flow of traffic to alleviate
traffic jams and things of that nature
and so those are some really interesting
applications of reinforcement learning
that are coming out but how could it go
wrong so one of my favorite examples of
reinforcement learning going wrong is a
floor cleaning that vacuums so if you
think about a Roomba for example if you
set it loose and you decided okay I'm
gonna let this thing trained in
reinforcement learning and let's say the
the reward system that I've set up is
going to reward it by so it gets a
reward if it minimizes the amount of
dirt that it sees right so to us
we're thinking okay this is kind of like
the peanut butter and jelly example that
Alisa brought up earlier right to us
we're thinking okay so it's gonna vacuum
up the dirt it will see luster it gets a
reward it's gonna be great
well one of these actually decided to
see less dirt by turning off its camera
right and so so you have to be very
careful you know how you set up your
reward systems and we'll talk about how
you can fix that you know later on the
other thing specific to health care
related to reinforcement learning is
that if you think about randomized
exploration healthcare that's a really
dangerous kind of situation right so
let's say you're trying to find the best
prescription drugs for different kinds
of ailments you can't exactly tell
computer okay just try all these
different medications on different
patients and see which ones work the
best right because yeah obviously you're
gonna hurt some people so it's really
not a good application and reinforcement
learning you have to be really careful
how you use those okay
computer vision so autonomous cars have
a lot of problems right still it's why
they're not fully autonomous
unfortunately because I'm a terrible
driver and can't wait to get in one um
but this this is a really interesting
kind of situation that arose when cars
first started to identify traffic signs
and so you can see this stop sign has a
couple of black and white stickers on it
and what that does is it will actually
full a computer vision algorithm into
thinking that stop sign is a 65 mile per
hour speed limit sign and so you can
imagine how big of a problem that would
be for an autonomous car it's gonna you
know maybe speed up when it should be
stopping okay and so and we can kind of
talk a little bit about why it happens
this way because for us we see a stop
sign there's so much red on there and
you kind of think how could just a few
stickers full of computer algorithm our
computer vision vision algorithm well
this is kind of how a neural net
architecture looks and you can see the
two layers in the middle the the first
layers are what's called an input layers
so that's just all the data you're
feeding in
and then you have your hidden layers and
your output layer which is making your
prediction of what something is well for
these nodes in the hidden layer the
number of nodes that you have determines
how many features you can identify so
you can see if you go back to the stop
sign what's wrong way so if you go back
to the stop sign you can see that
essentially you have about four features
that have been identified that make a 65
mile per hour so there's four stickers
here which means there are essentially
four features that will distinguish the
65 mile per hour traffic sign from any
other sign and that's kind of what
neural Nets do they find the important
distinguishing characteristics and so
when you get into these neural net
architectures if you were to make these
big enough so that you could really
identify every pixel instead of just the
important edges that'd be great that's
kind of how our brains work our brains
actually are estimated to contain about
100 billion neurons so what we're
looking at and even these really deep
architectures which this this is a
simple neural net but even in the really
deep architectures we're not getting
anywhere near that number right and so
in order to even do something like that
we would have have to have way more
compute power and time than what we have
because the deeper these things get the
more time they take to train the more
compute-intensive they are and so it's
really just not possible to get that
level of detail
ok cyber-security I'm not a
cybersecurity expert but this is
definitely a concern especially when
you're in healthcare you have to think
about all of the connections if you're
working in the cloud maybe the cloud
platform is secure but your connection
to the cloud may not be if you're
working on Prem you just have to be very
careful about any connections that you
have to the outside world but because
for all kinds of cyber security issues
especially when you're dealing with pH I
so job security this is a big one right
and I deal with this a lot well my job
be replaced by a compute
well we went through this once before in
the Industrial Revolution and you know
from one example tractors were invented
right well we needed fewer farmers after
tractors were invented because one
farmer can handle a lot more land with
the help of a tractor and so job
security is definitely concerned
absolutely computers will start doing
more of what humans do it's not really
clear how quickly that will happen but
you know there are definitely it
definitely will cause them some change
and we could talk about this a little
later as well
okay so all of those are issues to AI
but does anybody know what the biggest
barrier to AI is right now exactly yeah
exactly right so this is kind of the
state of data for a data scientist right
now right like we're asked to build
these big beautiful like stone Islands
and they give us data that's like that
marble gravel up in the top right corner
anyway put together this big beautiful
island with gravel right you're going
whoa it's not gonna look like that yeah
there's just impossible there's no way
that you're gonna get from marble grab
gravel to that and and so what we what
we're starting to do in my work and my
job as we're going back to the systems
that are collecting data and we're
trying to collect better data right fix
the systems get rid of freeform text
fields and so what we're doing is we're
trying to go back for this example it's
like the picture on that on that sorry
the left over here the marble quarry
we're getting big slabs instead of small
gravel so we can do better things with
it okay so why don't computers think
like we do well neural networks like you
saw before those are kind of patterned
after the way that the brain functions
so our brain has a bunch of synapses and
neurons and it essentially sends
electrical signals from node to node and
sometimes those single signals are
stronger than other times and that's
kind of what
that works too so it's it's going to
send a signal node to node and some of
those nodes will be turned on and some
of those nodes will be turned off
similar to the way that our synapses
work in our brain and there they were
actually when they were started there
were two guys who who thought up neuro
simple neural neural network
architecture back in I think the 50s it
was a long time ago and they were
actually saying you know I think if you
had these complex logic gate systems
where everything's binary one or zero
you can actually come up with a really
good result and that's how neural
networks started so if computers are
patterned after our brain functionality
why can't they think like we do well
like I said earlier our brains have a
hundred billion nodes essentially in
them and we can't come anywhere near
that but also there's more to it than
that and it's a data problem as well
because if you think about how we get
data as humans since the time we were
born 24 hours a day every day that we're
alive we have information coming in we
have people around us who are teaching
us things we're seeing new things we
have information that are coming from
all of our senses every nerve in our
body is providing us with data our eyes
our ears we have a sense of taste
we are just constantly collecting data
and computers don't have that ability
and one because they don't have all the
sensors that we have in our human bodies
so they are really limited by what we
can give them and by how they're able to
collect it and so I think it's it's
really more an issue of computers not
having the prolific amount of data that
we get even less so than it is just not
having the same number of you know nodes
that we have in our brain so how do we
deal with these issues right so I hope I
haven't instilled with you all
hopelessness in regard to the future of
AI because my talk is artificial
intelligence the future of healthcare
right so there are ways to reduce the
risks of these issues so in terms of
biased data this is a difficult one and
it really starts with awareness right
being aware of your data
being aware of our biases as humans
being aware of what past biases might be
in our data and trying to figure out how
we can remove information that can be
used for biases and that doesn't just
stop with removing like if you're trying
to stop a gender bias in the in regard
to like the Amazon HR example even
removing the gender doesn't necessarily
remove the bias because there are other
things in the data that can imply a bias
one thing that can help especially in
that example is balancing out your data
set if you know you have like a hundred
women and a thousand men you know you
can augment your data on women and you
can sub under sample your data on men
and come to a more balanced data set and
that might help with some of the bias in
addition to removing data that's
specifically going to trigger bias like
race gender age etc with reinforcement
learning you can create tests or pseudo
environments for randomly exploring
pathways and so if you have some simpler
problems you might be able to kind of
give it a fake patient right and have it
try different things with a fake patient
and if it starts to perform very well
then you can remove the random
exploration feature of the reinforcement
system take the training and put it into
practice so that's one way that you can
take a trained reinforcement learning
system and put it into practice without
it exploring on real patients you also
need to consider all the actions
available to the actor while you're
designing your reward framework so
remember when we were talking about the
vacuum cleaner and how it was rewarded
by seeing less dirt and it turned off
its camera well the failure there was
not recognizing all the actions
available to the vacuum right so when
you're creating your reward system you
have to say what are all the things that
it can do what of these things could
affect the reward and you can either
remove some of the actions available so
maybe you just don't allow it to turn
its camera off anymore or you could
change your rewards to say
you have to see you Esther while your
camera is operable right so these are
kinds of some ways that you can resolve
the issues some of the issues with
reinforcement learning so data integrity
and job security and really just about
any other problem well um ways that we
can work with this to alleviate some of
the issues peer review consider the
appropriateness of your solution so just
thinking very deeply about your problems
talking to your peers making sure
everything is reviewed and also as other
industries are regulated and have
training requirements and licensing and
boards to review their work I think at
AI grows we're going to need some of
that in this field as well so another
fix for a lot of the problems that are
currently exist in AI our human in the
loop systems which actually are some my
favorite AI systems and can anyone think
of any popular human-in-the-loop systems
that are available to us today yeah oh
yes CAPTCHAs that's somewhere I hate
those
yes that's correct that's definitely
human in the way so also Google search
right so Google's search algorithm pays
attention to the actions of its users
for page or page rank algorithm so if
you click on one of the top search
results and quickly bounce off it's
going to change the PageRank algorithm
based on the fact that you seem to be an
incorrect result for you based on the
search that you had so it's learning
from the people who are using the system
and it continues to learn so every time
you interact with Google search it
learns from you it's also starting to
predict the text that you're going to
type in which is interesting sometimes
and has its own biases another one
stitch fix is a recommender system with
the human fashion expert in the loop so
the recommender system makes a
recommendation but there's still a human
there like interacting with the with the
with the
customer who's buying the clothes and
getting feedback and adjusting the
system and so the system continues to
learn from the fashion designer who's
working on the other end so there are a
lot of human in the loop systems and
these are really really great ways to
develop AI so remember I said AI to
think of say I as a system so even
outside of these human human in the loop
systems AI systems still interact with
and learn from humans so even if you
don't have someone directly in there
like if you're looking at Netflix
recommendation system it doesn't have an
expert there that's adjusting the
opinions but it's still learning from
its users and it still needs users to
use the platform in order to learn and
so these systems really need to be user
friendly and so an AI system can be kind
of symbiotic in that way right so you
have human performance as augmented by
the AI but also the AI continues to
learn from the humans that are using it
so this is also really important when
you're talking about job security right
because we're not sure how fast AI is
going to start replacing some jobs but
these human in the loop systems are
great and they also help with the
transition so if you think about medical
related AI right so I work with some
radiologists and we were talking about
AI with radiology and you know King
computers really read medical images and
say oh yeah there's a tumor there
there's not a tumor there or whatever
and you know the radiologists are
getting really nervous as we're having
this conversation because they're going
you know are they gonna replace me my
you're not gonna have a job is radiology
going to cease to exist and I'm thinking
you know I don't think that will happen
for a really long time for all kinds of
reasons
but also I think it's gonna be more of a
transition to where those same doctors
are still gonna be required to interpret
the results of the AI so as AI would
learn from them right so they create
reports they look at images they I
sitting in the background looking at the
same images looking at them as they're
creating the reports and it can kind of
learn from them and start doing more
it'll / start predicting hey I think
this should be in the report
I think this should be in the report
they can adjust it and correct it and as
the AI gets better and they spend less
time doing the reports they can spend
more time with the patient's explaining
to them the results of what they read or
the doctors sometimes they you know
sometimes they talk directly to patients
and sometimes they talk to other doctors
but there's still an interpretation
element that's really important in all
this and generally speaking in AI I
think that's kind of the direction
things are gonna go in like people need
to understand when they should be
correcting AI how it works when they
shouldn't you know when when should you
trust in a I have result and when should
weigh when should you correct it right
and there's a learning curve there and
we're always going to need humans in
some capacity with these systems and I
think the focus is going to come for the
human users more in interpreting and
understanding how to use the AI then
doing what the AI used to what you know
what the what the AI has started doing
for them they will no longer be doing
but instead they'll be interpreting the
results and making sure that they're
applied correctly okay
so here's an example of a clean data
that you get from a human on the loop
system so I have always hated chat BOTS
like a lot and also partly I think it's
worse for me because my early focus in
data science and AI was in natural
language processing and so when I get
into a chat but that has freeform text
fields I'm always trying to think how
was a computer gonna interpret what I'm
typing in right and I'm always trying to
think like the computer and then I get
just get really frustrated sometimes
like I could ask a question I know it's
not going to understand and like can I
just get through to a person you know
and so what I really like that they've
been doing the chat BOTS lately is these
predictive fields right so instead of
having the the freeform text fields
it'll ask a question like this one says
uh what does it say I can't read it from
here don't catch that I've been working
so hard in the studio so anyway it's
saying do you want to respond with
carrion shop or try on sunglasses well
this is kind of a funny
example because this person made the bot
that has the options and somebody still
type dancer in and then it couldn't
understand it right so two things on
this like one having the textfield
having the the tags instead of a free
form text text field gives you way
better data it's a better user
experience etc with the human responses
again like you really have to think of
these systems because you have people
using the system and if people don't
know how to use the system properly or
or you've not built it in a way that it
makes it easy for them to use you're
gonna get junk right and it's not gonna
work well you really have to think
through how you're designing the whole
system and not just the machine learning
or the backend AI and the smart
algorithms okay so this is kind of how I
envision an entire AI system right so
you've got UX UI who does the user
research how are people going to
interact with this thing is it easy and
intuitive for them to use and you know
while at the same time functioning the
way that we need it to function and then
you've got kind of the data science
machine learning piece in the backend
and software engineering obviously for
to build out the front-end and whatever
else whatever other pieces that you have
and so this was kind of what I think is
required to get these systems up and
going and this is just kind of another
illustration of how the human in the
loop fits in there to be human using the
computer the data goes to like a data
warehouse and it goes through your
machine learning and then it's going to
make some predictions that are returned
to the human the humans going to make a
selection that selection is going to go
back into data and the loop just kind of
continues to repeat as the users use the
system in the the AI makes the
predictions okay so are there problems
with human and Lou Pai systems yeah of
course most notably when humans rely too
heavily on the AI so I think something I
always think of with autonomous cars
right now
there's this in-between period that's
almost worse than being fully autonomous
or not autonomous at all because people
aren't paying attention so if you think
about like the uber self-driving cars
you know yeah they've got a human
sitting there but they're not ready to
react that's why the uber hit a
pedestrian down in Arizona right because
there was a human driver but she's not
ready to drive she's just the cars
driving you know so she's not prepared
to stop immediately and the other thing
about that system is so uber put their
autonomous technology into a Volvo and
the uber autonomous technology actually
turned off the Volvo's emergency braking
systems and so when they went back and
investigated what happened they found
that the AI did detect the person and it
knew it needed to stop and it had time
to stop the car but it couldn't stop
because they couldn't engage the
emergency braking systems because their
system had turned off that functionality
and so you know it's just another
example of how these you really have to
think very carefully about how you're
designing the system as a whole and how
people will actually interact with it
and then the other problem that occurs
with humans a loop is like I said before
when they don't understand how the AI
systems are designed or intended to be
used and they use them incorrectly so I
think you know like I said as we
transition jobs to more AI focused
systems there's going to be some
training you know there's still going to
be people that are needed but there's
gonna we're also gonna need a lot of
training people and how to really use
and understand these systems okay so
that's all I had any questions what do
you use to reward an AI program oh it's
it's like a point system so like in pong
for example if it actually hits the ball
it's supposed to misses the ball it'll
get a point if it misses the ball it
doesn't get a point and so it wants to
hit the ball as many times as possible
and that maximizes its reward and you
know what it could also be so you think
about we think the word reward always
means like you're getting something good
right but
in this context they also use the term
reward as like a could also mean
punishment right so like for example
with the vacuum if it sees dirt that's a
punishment because it wants to minimize
the amount of dirt that it sees right so
you can kind of think of it it can kind
of go both ways it's a little foggy on
the vocabulary there also many more
questions for Kristin come over there
so with the neural network I really like
your example of think a great example
that I've seen implemented as a neural
network calculator heavier basically
it's when you added you feed it a bunch
of training data saying 1 plus 1 2 plus
2 and everything else and then at the
end that gives you a calculator and then
you add up simple numbers like 2 plus 2
and it gives you three point nine five
six seven four because it doesn't really
know what two plus two is it just knows
the probability that two plus two equals
this certain number is this right so
there's always a trailing number yeah
but so how does that help with
delivering health care is that what you
do I guess to use artificial
intelligence to help deliver the health
care or you're using it for I'm not sure
what you're using the neural the neural
networks and artificial intelligence for
as far as the health care goes yeah so
you can use it for a couple of different
things and in terms of like actually is
so the example you gave we computed a
two plus two really bad use of a neural
network but if you are doing two plus
two like you can actually a lot of the
packages now we'll probably I would
probably treat it as a cost but I'm
gonna classification example in which
case you can get the predicted class as
well as the probability of the predicted
class so I think that might resolve that
issue I don't know how you get the
training data for that weird anyway yeah
so there are a lot of ways that like
machine learning and AI can work in
healthcare right now what I look at is
how to augment like doctor performance
right how to make their jobs easier
things that are kind of mundane they
don't like to do over and over again try
and automate some of those processes so
for example like dictating reports not
fun and they're saying the same thing
over and over again right so if you can
kind of use predictive text generation
algorithms kind of like Google does in
their search now so when you start to
type something in and like finish it for
you and sometimes it's right sometimes
it's not so you know you
have the radiologists sitting there
looking at it and saying yeah that's
right no no that's totally wrong and
they fix it so that kind of thing I
think are really good applications of AI
and healthcare field specifically and
there are other things you can kind of
put data analytics into work so if
you're trying to get a better idea of
like how long it should take to do a
procedure right and and so let's say
there's something let's say it's so back
to radiology
I think you're dictating report right
well obviously the longer the report
gets the longer it probably takes you to
complete that particular reading but
also there might be certain mores in
that report that indicate something that
would make it take longer
like if it's oncology related it might
take longer than if it's just something
simple like broken bone kind of review
well you can use AI to kind of detect
that and adjust the like assignment of
work value for that particular item
right so there are a lot of ways that AI
can kind of sit in the background and
and help people both in data analytics
and and actually the work performance
time for another question if there's
anybody's got a question for Kristen
when I go over here for purely
efficiency sake
is there any healthcare application that
you have in mind maybe something that
you can't work on just due to
feasibility but it's something that AI
would be a really good application for
I'm not sure I understand
a healthcare problem that AI would be a
good solution for um yeah I mean yeah
the ones that I just mentioned I I don't
know off the top of my head I don't have
anything in my mood kind of two
questions oh wow that was really close
so do you guys interface with stuff the
software like epic and stuff - um so not
directly but yeah
I definitely have to use api's for
transcription software and because I'm
not building my own transcription
software they've got stuff that works
really well for that yeah so absolutely
they're definitely the leak image
reading platforms as well and I don't
directly work with epic or another what
do you call it EMR system but products
that I work with interface with those
and then I interface with the other
products so yeah well there's a lot of
API integrations generally in AI I find
so also what's your toolset what do you
use to generate these role networks I
well a lot of different things
um I've used actually you know I fight
scikit-learn has a really simple neural
nut I can't remember what it's called
off the top of my head but there's a
regression one in the classification one
and honestly for a lot of problems like
I always start simple and that one works
quite well if I need to get fancier
usually tensorflow I like to work with
Karis better than tensorflow sometimes I
have to get deeper into it so I've got
to use tensorflow natively and I used to
use at the Theano begin on Keros some in
natural language processing and haven't
done that in a while and then sometimes
I write my own so do you verify whether
simple classifiers work or do you even
always go straight for neural networks
no I do not
that's a great question actually I think
someone mentioned this earlier I'm not
sure for the solicitor or someone else
but actually depends on the amount of
data that you have right so I'm Andrew
eing very famously and in the neural
network world anyway has a data
visualization I should really put my
presentation and it kind of shows
there's a curve right and it depends on
how much data you have what really
starts to perform well and you don't
really hit good performance with neural
net networks usually unless you hit like
maybe around a hundred thousand examples
and that also depends on
and how many classes you have is well
right so like if you have a hundred
thousand examples but you have a hundred
classes that still might not be a lot of
data for the type of thing that you're
doing if you have hundred thousand
examples in two different classes so
it's just turning images of cats and
dogs it'll probably work a whole lot
better so but no actually if you don't
have a lot of data a lot of times
simpler solutions do work well it's not
always the number of rows you have
either so with the natural language
processing specifically usually have
really wide data so even if you don't
have a whole lot of examples because
your data is so wide neural networks
usually perform better for those I find
but other other problems no I usually
start as simple as I can do one more
question do you have any library
recommendations for reinforcement
learning like if I know I have an MDP or
pom DP what should I use to solve it so
unity platform is a great platform for
that I haven't done a ton of
reinforcement learning myself there's
actually okay let me take the back
there's a library called
Ray I think are a why I think if I
remember right it was design from by
some students from Stanford and it
actually does I think distributing
computing but it also works with
reinforcement learning so you might
check that out and also their website
will have some resources as well I
believe you mentioned NLP did you
compare for example just simple tf-idf
in an SVM yeah yes we found that often
they're really hard to beat at with
neural net yeah that's actually how I
started an LP I actually used a SVM was
one of the first tools lately hasn't
been working as well as neural nets for
me and the particular problems that I've
been working on but the the simple
neural net that's I can't learn how it's
working pretty well on it and usually I
don't go to Kharis and
nothing else is working
[Music]